hello and welcome to reality check it is
good to be here again seems a gain spot
have any fire alarms as of last been
here Google I like it
and a new earthquake machine wait a
minute the old earthquake machine was
fine aho don't be fooled humble here and
that's just some sensational acting
combined with the latest in motion
graphics whoa
but of course one bombshell that is
dropping in a few weeks is the release
of Fallout 76 and perhaps more than any
Fallout game in the past 76 emphasizes
survival and rebuilding this is because
the landscape of West Virginia where the
game takes place is not a desolate
wasteland thanks to it not being
directly bombed or fully irradiated
happy days so naturally reality check is
here to find out how one might go about
surviving following a real-life Fallout
76 apocalypse in a two-part special
we're gonna investigate the tips and
tricks you might need to survive and
maybe even thrive in a real-life Fallout
76 world
[Music]
when it comes to survivalism i am
useless the only animal I know how to
hunt is the humble haggis and very easy
to catch they just go around in circles
so I tracked down a survivalist expert
to help me out it's professor Luis
Darnell author of the knowledge how to
rebuild our world from scratch he's a
genuine expert on the subtle art of
post-apocalyptic survival burn your
enemies burn them afire kill them with
fire
okay let's start with the basics I think
welcome back to reality check Lewis and
it's not your first time but this the
first time you brought a whole table of
things what's going on life tables so
what I brought with me is a whole
collection of every items things you
could use to help you survive an
apocalypse what's the very first thing I
should do dying of starvation running
out of food
dying is a something to motivate your
mind and the lack of food will kill you
in a matter of weeks but what will kill
you long before then is is dehydration
is as a lack of water so your top
priority is going to be fine sources of
natural water and then purify them it
would be so frustrating to have survived
the end of the world a celebratory glass
of water you have a celebrated drink of
water and you end up dying of typhoid or
Coral these are the kind of really
simple to prevent waterborne diseases
now purifying water is actually one of
the very first things full-out 76 tells
you to do in the game and I believe
that's by boiling the water so what
should I do in in real life
I mean boiling water works the plumbers
it uses a lot of fuel and one really
nice one really clever alternative is
known as sodus or solar disinfection and
even today this is being taught around
the developing world from developing
nations to stop some akha million people
a year dying of easily preventable
waterborne diseases so which item on our
table is all you need just an empty
plastic bottle put your suspect water in
that something you've taken from a lake
or a river and then just leave it out in
the sunshine for a day or two come back
to it and then because you've
essentially constrained that water to be
very shallow the author of violet rays
and the sunlight can pass straight
through it and then kill or inactivate
any germs any waterborne diseases in
that water
okay so I'm gonna survive at least a few
weeks hopefully with my lovely clean
water but what's the next kind of
priority on my list what do I need to
make so you're also gonna want to
harness fire fire will cook food for you
so again you don't get sick and die off
eating a bad meal Fire will keep the
cold at bay and you don't die of
exposure keep your enemies if they keep
you up enemies at bay you can burn them
with fire but fire has just been
fantastically useful for thousands of
years for making things and transforming
substances and materials for us so
things like hair spray or chapstick also
things that make you look great celine
these are great for everyday grooming of
the apocalypse but these actually will
help you stay alive as well because
these are all accelerant they will help
a fire get started and what you're
looking for is that joyful symbol right
there which is do not mix with fire and
if your life depends on it that's
exactly the kind of flammable stuff you
want to spray onto your kindling or
tinder to try to get that alight
another thing that I know I'm gonna need
in the post apocalypse is medicine
because obviously I'm gonna get sick or
I'm gonna get hurt in fallout 76 you
have stimpaks but but what's the kind of
real life option - to keep myself alive
in that way
yes Tim back to of great things to find
in the fallout world and then the game
but they they don't really exist in the
real world there's no panacea you can
take that will cure you of any disease
or any injury the sort of things you'll
want to look out for and scavenge and
forage for in the world around you
would be the kind of medications you're
familiar with so things like antibiotics
they've been studies done by the US
military for example for the founder -
antibiotics
still work and don't become poisonous
decades of the best before date if you
can't find medications like that what
you could do is find a bottle of vodka
or alcohol or other kind of concentrated
spirits which is great for a
post-apocalyptic party also you save
your life and if you've got a nasty gash
or nasty wound do not want to get some
kind of infection in a world without
hospitals and a good glug of vodka or
disinfect the wound for you but
ultimately you want to close that wound
as quickly as you can to stop the
bacteria getting in and all you would
need is just to apply a line of
superglue to hold together the edges and
that will form a physical power that'll
stop the bacteria getting to that wound
and you pick up an infection when you
can't do anything about it so when it
comes to food in the game you can
scavenge things just lying around in
fighting when you kill creatures you can
kind of take steaks and then go and go
and cook them but what would your advice
be to me as a survivor and a real-life
post-apocalypse when it comes to eating
sooner or later you are going to have to
reinvent agriculture but again this in
this immediate aftermath you will be
able to scavenge and forage for what you
need and if you find yourself to an
abandoned supermarket hasn't been hit
too badly you'll be able to find shelves
of canned food just waiting there and
again something like like tinned food
will keep decades after its best before
date nationally when I was researching
for my book the knowledge I calculated
that an average supermarket can keep a
single person alive for about 55 years
or 63 years if you're happy to eat all
the canned dog food and cat
food as well if what is this is this dog
I have no idea the labels come off but I
think if it reached the point of trying
to keep himself alive by eating cat food
I would be looking for another escape
route well that's it for part one where
we hopefully learned how to survive a
real-life Fallout 76 apocalypse but what
did you think let me know your thoughts
on Lucy's tips and tricks and if you
have any survival ideas of your own you
can put them down in the comments below
or you can tweet to me directly at cam 4
as Rob next week in part two lewis will
take us a step further how are we going
to go about rebuilding in a fallout 76
world see you then play it on the
world's most powerful console